تغيرت ارقام العام الجديد ولم يتغير كما
يبدو حال الاوكرانيين فالقصف الروسي لازال
العنوان الابرز ليومياتهم ومعاناتهم يطالب
بانتظام العاصمه كاف وشرق وجنوب البلاد
بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره اين اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها استهدفت
مصانعها في العديد من المناطق الاخرانيه
ضربات المكثفه باسلحه بعيده المدى و عاليه
الدقه
وتم تدمير المجمع الصناعي العسكري الخاصه
يرحب الجنود الاوكرانيون في خنادق الجبهه
الشرقيه بالعام الجديد بحزن ورغبه في
مواصله القتال حتى النصر كما قالوا وهي
الرغبه التي يتقاسمها معهم رئيسهم فرض
ميرسي
على العدو في جبهات القتال واشكر العاملين
في مجال الطاقه
التي تعمل على تقليل الانقطاعات
الكهربائيه بسبب القصف الارهابي الروسي في
مدينه بخموت بدون نت اشتدت المعارك مع
استمرار القوات الاوكرانيه في التقدم وادت
اشهر من القتال العنيف الى تحويل المدينه
الى انقاض فيما يعيش من بقي من
الاوكرانيين هناك في ظل ظروف قاسيه
يمكنك ان ترى ذلك ليس لدينا الغاز موجود
نعيش في هذا البيت اين ساذهب الان بعد
سلسله من الهزائم العسكريه بدات روسيا في
شهر اكتوبر الماضي باستهداف البناء
التحتيه الاوكرانيه تاركه الملايين من
الاوكرانيين في الصقيع والظلام